FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
56 of the weekly Google
Cloud plus Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm all right.
I'm a little sad.
It's the last
episode of the year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm also super sad.
I'm actually kind
of looking forward
to a little bit of a break.
But yeah, it's going
to be sad not to get
to talk to you for three weeks.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's going to be really sad.
I'm going to miss you.
I'm going to miss everyone.
It's going to be sad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and we know
when we're coming back already.
So, just so you know,
we will be back soon.
MARK MANDEL: January
18, I believe,
is the date we've agreed upon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: January
18, which is also Wednesday.
In the meanwhile, you can
listen to previous episodes,
if you want to.
But today we do have an episode.
Today's our last episode, and we
decided to make it a little bit
special.
So we called the episode
"A Year in Review."
And that's pretty much
what we're going to do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're going to talk through
all the kind of things
we talked about, pick out
some of our favorite episodes,
and our favorite cool
things of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Our
favorite launches,
like what happened in 2016
that is worth mentioning today.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, I
thought you said lunches and not
launches.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We can
also talk about that.
MARK MANDEL: I've had
some really good lunches.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We have very good food
at the Google office.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But before that, we
have the cool thing of the week.
The last cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: The cool things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The cool things?
MARK MANDEL: We have multiple.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh
yeah, there's two lines.
There's actually the last--
MARK MANDEL: There's three.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Three?
MARK MANDEL: Three.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, my god.
OK.
So there's three of them.
That's why you had blank
lines in the show notes,
so we can actually follow.
So there's three of them, and
they're the three last ones
of the year.
So I hope they're worth it.
The first one is--
I'm going to let
you talk about
it, because I know
you're very excited about it.
MARK MANDEL: I am.
I am.
So I think this is
pretty exciting.
Everyone knows I'm
well into games.
We have partnered with a
company called Improbable.
Basically, you can
think of that as
a like, massively multiplayer
online game as a service.
So if you're looking to build
a massively multiplayer game
online, or a large-scale
simulation or virtual world,
any sort of games in
that sort of aspect,
we've partnered with them and
such that they have a program
as well for people
to use their platform
for a heavily subsidized amount,
which is super, super cool.
So they run on us, and we
provide that power to them.
And they provide
that power to you.
It's super, super cool.
The company name is Improbable.
They have product
a named Spatial OS.
And the partnership,
literally, just
got announced right now,
which is pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
looks really cool.
All the images I'm
seeing, and the videos,
they look like
something I would play.
So I'm very excited about
seeing all the new games
and new companies that are
going to be joining this effort
and making new cool things
on the Google Cloud platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Then, as well as that, we have
the new Google Cloud client
libraries for four
key services, which
I thought were pretty cool.
It looks like we've basically
been building these client
libraries as the
libraries that people
can use for all the languages
we support, for all the services
that we have on Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You said
there's four of them.
So there is BigQuery,
Google Cloud Datastore,
Stackdriver Login, and
Google Cloud Storage.
And they are available
for seven languages.
So I'm going to start
with Go, obviously--
MARK MANDEL: Obviously.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I'll
leave Java for the end.
No.
So we have Go, Java, CSharp,
NodeJS, PHP, Python, and Ruby.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And I think what's really
cool about these, too,
is that each library is very
idiomatic to the language.
So if you're using these
libraries, it's not like,
oh this is obviously
a Go thing who was
written by a Java programmer.
No.
None of that.
It's very much idiomatic
to the language
so that you know that when
you go to use the client,
it's exactly the same as
you would use any other SDK
within your ecosystem.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Of all my sites,
I know that the Go team
has been heavily involved
with these efforts
for the Go libraries,
so they look really good.
I am very excited about it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And finally, pretty exciting,
Kubernetes 1.5, literally
just released.
Is it really-- like,
what is going on?
It's the end of the year.
So much stuff is happening.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I guess that
there's a production freeze,
and we cannot put
things in production.
Instead we just do
open source stuff.
I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's so
much cool stuff going on.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So Kubernetes is 1.5.
Huge number of major themes
around stateful sets,
or pet sets, improved
federations support,
more simplified cluster
deployment, which is great.
It's pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I feel like there's
kind of a tradition,
that we've always
done an episode
every single time there's a
new version of Kubernetes.
And maybe next year we
should start with that.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
We should.
Yeah.
We should definitely have
someone to talk about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I guess it's time to
go with the main content.
And the plan is, we're going
to start talking about the 2016
episodes.
And we're going to
be talking about
the most downloaded
episodes and then
our personal favorite episodes,
which are not the same.
And then at the end,
we'll be talking
about our favorite cool
things of the week, which
is kind of a vague term to
say all the cool things that
happened.
So it will be more like themes,
what happened, like cool, I'm
going to say announcements
because I probably mispronounce
launches.
MARK MANDEL: That's all right.
I have an accent, too.
I quote, unquote "mispronounce"
things all the time,
depending on where
you come from.
Yeah, no, I think
this is really cool.
I think it's something that we
can kind of go back and look
at what happened at Google
Cloud Platform over 2016.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's a
crazy amount of things.
MARK MANDEL: It's a
crazy amount of things,
and it really is kind of a
year in review of Google Cloud
Platform, and what
it is, and what's
happened in the last year.
I mean, we're not even going
to touch on everything,
but some of our
highlights, which I think
is super exciting,
and really kind of
gives us a little
history of what's
happened in the past year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's kind of
crazy to think about not that
long ago, there were things
like GKE was not really a thing.
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And all of a sudden,
oh, it's like it's
totally a thing.
MARK MANDEL:
Totally a thing now.
It's absolutely a thing.
You we're talking
about 2016 episodes.
So starting there, if we go back
and we look at the analytics--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I propose we
go backwards from number five
to number one--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: To
make it more exciting.
MARK MANDEL: Make
it more exciting.
Then we can have like a drum
roll, and like long pauses,
like reality TV.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You'll add
that on post-production.
So on number five,
we have episode 43,
which is GRPC at CoreOS
with Brandon Philips.
Loved this episode.
MARK MANDEL: Loved this episode.
Love this tech.
Super interesting episode to
see how a customer is using
to your GRPC, and how they
were able to get performance
benefits out of it.
But again, GRPC, that's
kind of 2016 I feel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a totally new thing,
and people are very, very
excited about the new tech.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
really seeing that.
And across the industry,
I've seen people using that.
I think it's a really
interesting piece
of technology.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Number four.
We have episode 37.
GKE 1.3, so two versions
ago, with Carter Morgan.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, love this.
Love this.
Also because Carter Morgan
is now a developer advocate.
He's part of developer
advocacy team.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
He got on the podcast,
and since then, he
could not stop talking.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty much.
So I expect people will be
seeing him around and about.
But any podcast about
Kubernetes or Container Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
GKE and Kubernetes
have been a pretty successful
theme over the years.
Yeah, that's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
Anything about container
orchestration and management
has been huge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Number three.
It's another open
source project.
It is also incredibly
successful-- TensorFlow,
Episode 31, TensorFlow
with Eli Bixby.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
another great episode.
TensorFlow makes my head hurt,
but it's super, super cool.
And Eli gets it
to a huge degree.
I mean, actually, it's
kind of interesting.
You look at it, like, out
of the top five, well,
actually technically four--
and we'll go back to it--
but four of them
are open source--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: --work
inside Google.
And given the history of
open source at Google,
and how we used to do things,
and how we do things now,
it's pretty amazing to
see the sort of success
we've had across the board.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
definitely a good thing
that we are open sourcing as
much technology as we can.
I'm very excited about
2017 and see what we're
going to be open-sourcing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah I think
we're on a good thing-- the way
we manage open source
products, the way we
build communities, the way that,
I think, we kind of release
it and let go of it, in a lot of
ways, as well, is really huge.
It makes me very
excited about the future
of open source at Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and my favorite piece,
my favorite moment of
the TensorFlow episode
was when Eli explained
what a tensor was.
And I understood it.
And it was like, oh.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, oh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And that is new.
Yeah, I never-- I
thought it was too hard.
It's like Monet, you know?
MARK MANDEL: Everything
comes back to Haskell.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So on number two,
we have number 44,
Cloud Endpoints with Dan
Ciruli and Sepehr Ebrahimzadeh.
And I am very, very
happy with this episode
being so successful because
I've been talking lately
a lot about Cloud Endpoints.
I'm working on a
bunch of videos.
And we're going to be
launching-- it's going
to becoming GA sometime soon.
And it's a lot of really
cool things coming on
in Cloud Endpoints.
MARK MANDEL: It's interesting.
I personally, because I sit
in that microservices space
so much, didn't see
this one coming.
It was a bit of a
surprise for me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
but it went crazy,
a crazy amount of people.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's done really well.
And I suppose that
makes sense, right?
Like, generally, a lot of
people are building APIs.
Like, you can't really get away
from that, in some way, shape,
or form.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
APIs, if you can microservice
this, you have Cloud Endpoints.
And you also have GKE, which
is also used for microservices,
and also the GRPC.
So out of the five, four--
MARK MANDEL: That's fair.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I said four.
I kind of told what
the number one is now.
MARK MANDEL: But you don't know.
We don't know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We don't know.
So yeah, it might also
be because Dan and Sepehr
are such cool people.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
Number one.
Number Number one.
[DRUMMING]
MARK MANDEL: That's
our drum roll.
That's our drum roll.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's a very
sad drum roll, low budget.
And yeah, number one.
I'm going to let you say it
because I know you're so, so,
in love with this one.
MARK MANDEL: So
number one has two
of my favorite things in it.
Kubernetes, obviously,
and John Wilkes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That was episode 46, Borg and
Kubernetes with John Wilkes.
I mean, what can I say?
MARK MANDEL: It's John Wilkes.
So if you haven't
listened to this episode,
please go back to this episode.
It is super, super interesting.
John talks us through how Borg
works internally at Google.
My favorite thing
is when he talks
about building
systems for failure--
expecting that things
are going to fail
and, with that expectation,
building systems to make sure
they stay healthy and they
stay up, and basically
how Kubernetes came out of
those lessons learned from Borg.
John's one of my all-time
favorite people in tech.
And so I was super, super
happy, and super privileged,
and super honored to just sit
in a room and chat with him.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I got
to say, he's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: He is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I had so much
fun recording that episode.
And every single time I
listen to it again, it's like,
that was so much fun.
MARK MANDEL: That was so great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We said
we would interview him
again sometime.
So, you know, maybe 2017.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no.
I've already got a
reminder in the calendar.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that was, according
to the people's choice.
What about our top choice?
MARK MANDEL: So
my number top 3, I
picked out episode 52, a recent
one-- The Google Developer
Expert Summit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That was fun.
MARK MANDEL: That was fun.
I love talking to our GDEs.
They're amazing.
If you don't know the Google
Developer Expert Program,
it's external people
from the community
that we highlight and
add to our program.
They get a lot of benefits.
They get to come to us, and
talk to us, and cool stuff.
You should totally
listen to that episode,
because it's really awesome
to see the community
outside of Google that really
appreciate the products we do
and like to talk about
the products we do.
And if there's one
in your area, you
could talk to them about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: My favorite,
my number three episode,
is actually something
we've talked about,
which is episode 43.
GRPC at CoreOS with
Brandon Philips.
I thought it was
very interesting
because he was covering
some open source project
but it was not built by
Google, which is ETCD and many
of the things that CoreOS does,
and how go GRPC helped them
move from JSON to GRPC,
and why they did this,
and all the different
performance gains they had.
It was very interesting.
And also, Brandon Philips is
a very great communicator.
So I thought I learned a lot.
And I think that is
a very good episode.
If you're interested in
GRPC go check it out.
It's number 43.
MARK MANDEL: It's actually cool,
cause it's kind of full circle.
Like Kubernetes uses that ETCD.
ETCD now uses GRPC.
One thing layer
goes into another,
which goes into another.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
the magic of open source.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Cool.
So my number two, I had to do
something that at least touched
on games because games, fun.
I thought this was a
particularly cool one.
Episode 23.
If anyone's bought games
through Humble Bundle,
we had one of their
teammates there.
Andy Oxfeld, who had come
to speak to us about that.
My particular love for this
is that they ran on App Engine
And the big thing
for me was how they
talked about how the
scale that they got,
like the immediate spike of
traffic that they received
at the site for people
coming to buy games,
wouldn't have been possible
if they had gone with about
any other platform
because of the way we
can scale at App Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
was a very fun episode.
And also it's like the perfect
use case for App Engine,
really, because they have
a huge peak of traffic
and then the rest
is not that much.
So if you were running on
[INAUDIBLE] you would need--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, it would suck.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --10
times more, maybe.
I don't know how many--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it would be so high.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--more machines you
need to have j to handle
that given traffic.
MARK MANDEL: And then what would
you do with those machines?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
I don't know.
Play games or something.
MARK MANDEL: So what's
your number two?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: My
number two is episode 38,
and it's with one of my
favorite people, Paul Newson.
So we did this episode, Site
Reliability Engineering,
with Paul Newson.
And it is very interesting
because he tells us
about how Google does SRE,
Site Reliability Engineering.
And it's an amazing thing,
talking about SLOs and SLAs,
and how you don't want to have
100% availability because it's
a bad idea.
And if you could
reach that, you're
actually missing out on the
opportunity of experimenting
more and stuff like that.
And it's something that
I feel more people should
know about it.
I was reading the SRE book.
MARK MANDEL: The
book is fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: By the
way, we got it for free
because we got our
[INAUDIBLE] last week.
And every single one of the
people in the team got one.
And it's an amazing
book-- love it.
And yeah, he puts it
in such a nice way.
I love that episode.
MARK MANDEL: I love
that episode, too.
If you're into ops or monitoring
or any of that kind of stuff,
definitely have a listen.
It is so worth it.
And definitely get the book.
The book is fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, the
book is really, really good.
OK.
It's time for your number one.
MARK MANDEL: My number one.
So I will say I would have
said my number one, Borg
and Kubernetes with John Wilkes.
But we've already covered that.
So I'm going to
pick something else.
I'm going to pick
something else.
I'm going to go with the episode
we did with GCP Next Speakers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, that was fun.
MARK MANDEL: That
was loads of fun.
So our big premiere
conference Next--
we're doing it
again next year-- we
sat down with a
bunch of speakers
at the event, talked
to them about what they
were talking about at Next.
And some of them were Googlers.
Some of them were customers.
If you're interested in
going to Next next year
it would be well worth
listening to the episode
so that you can get a feel of
some of the stuff that probably
will be showing and
the sort of quality
that you can come to expect.
It's pretty high quality.
It was an amazing,
amazing, amazing event.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And I actually feel
like maybe we should also
mention that in episode 21
we did The Amazing Demos from
GCP Next with Instrument.
MARK MANDEL: That's
true as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
was a very good episode.
MARK MANDEL: I was really close
to putting that on the list.
I have to admit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
they're kind of a continuation
of each other.
So they're both
really good episodes
about all the things we
talked about doing GCP Next
and all the amazing
demos they had.
MARK MANDEL: And we
were only scratching
the surface of the event,
like just even then.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just
a tiny little bit
to give you an idea
of what goes on.
MARK MANDEL: Now your
number one, I think,
is a huge surprise.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is not JS with Node.
I love Justin, but
no it was not JS.
It was episode 25, Go On The
Cloud with Andrew Gerrand
and Chris Broadfoot.
It was so much fun.
I mean--
MARK MANDEL: It was.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We talked
about tweaking turkeys.
Like, come on.
MARK MANDEL: And one
of my favorite things
about this episode-- little
peek behind the scenes--
we totally did it
at the last minute.
Andrew was sitting
in the office.
He was just happening
to be in San Francisco.
And we were like, we should
get Andrew on the podcast.
And it was fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The best part is
I think it was one of the first
episodes, or-- at some point
I had to stop because we
were laughing way too much.
So, yeah, that was super fun.
But also very
interesting talking
about all the things
about why Go is cool,
and why GO works so
well in the cloud,
and what you can do
with it, and what APIs
are available, and
stuff like that.
So technically very interesting,
but also so much fun.
MARK MANDEL: So much fun.
Definitely an episode to listen
to if you're interested in Go,
or you're thinking
about using Go
and you just want to learn
more about the ecosystem
and what's available in it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or
if you want to know
what one Catalan sounds
when he's speaking
with three Australians.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
There is that as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that was fun.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, well, I
think that sort of
covers our list of episodes.
I mean, we could probably
talk about episodes
for hours and hours on end.
But why don't we talk about
our favorite cool things
of the week, as kind of a
backdrop to all the stuff
that's happened
inside Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So the first one
I'm going to go with is
all the effort that we
have done on education.
There's a bunch of things
we've done, but the fact
that we opened CP100A, which
is the Google Cloud Platform
foundations.
And you can go check it out
on cloud.google.com/training.
That is awesome.
There's a bunch of courses
that are really, really good.
You can go pass
exams if you want to,
but all on top of that,
if you're a student,
and you want to use
Google Cloud Platform,
we also announced the Google
Cloud Platform Education
Grants.
That is helping students use
our cloud for free so they can
learn and they can experiment.
And there's a lot of
things that they can do.
If you're a statistics
student, and you
can get to play with
things like BigQuery.
That is kind of an
amazing experience.
And then also some
Udacity courses.
And one of my favorite ones was
the Kubernetes class on Udacity
with--
MARK MANDEL: Some of
my favorite people.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --two of our
teammates now, we can say,
Kelsey Hightower
and Carter Morgan.
So yeah, all the
effort in education.
And also improving our
docs, and all the effort
that we did on basically
making our cloud more
friendly to beginners.
I think it's an
amazing, amazing effort.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
No, there's huge,
huge things happening
in the education space.
So that's pretty awesome.
Yeah, I definitely am a huge
fan of the education grant,
specifically.
I think it's great we're
getting into colleges.
Awesome.
So one of my favorite
things is just
looking at a number
of things we made
generally available this year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So many things.
MARK MANDEL: So many things.
I'm going to miss some.
I know I'm going to miss some.
But just rattling some off,
like Cloud SQL, Bigtable,
cloud datastore, router,
CDN went live, IAM, so--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Identity
and Access Management.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You're welcome.
MARK MANDEL: I totally
blanked on that for a minute.
Identity and access
management, that went live.
That's also a huge thing.
I'm sure I'm missing
some of the other stuff,
but just a huge list of
things that went GA this year
truly shows, I
think, the investment
that is going into Google
Cloud and the amount of stuff
that people have available.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
worst part about this is,
being a developer
advocate, you're
supposed to know all
of these things--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it
keeps on growing and growing.
MARK MANDEL: It keeps growing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it is very
good for our customers,
not as much for our team,
but lots of fun.
So I'm going to go with--
these are not really ordered
in any specific way, but
one of my favorite things
we talked about was Spotify.
Spotify moving to Google
Cloud platform was awesome.
The way our team was
involved with them
so they could get all the
infrastructure together
to make sure it was a successful
movement, it was great.
And also, all the things
that they published.
They wrote a bunch
of blog posts.
And there's one of them.
My favorite things was Paul
Lamere or "la-meer," whatever,
he tweeted something saying,
"Google's Big Query is
the bomb.
I can start with
2 billion things,
and compute summarize down to
20k in less than one minute."
And I think that the
fact that someone
calls one of your products "the
bomb" surrounded by asterisks,
that is very awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Very good.
Goal for 2017?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Get
more "the bombs."
MARK MANDEL: Well
there's that, but have
Spotify on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yes.
Yes.
If you're listening to us,
and you work for Spotify,
hello friend.
MARK MANDEL: Hello.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
want to interview you.
Yeah.
That was my-- I think that that
was a huge thing that happened.
I'm so happy about it.
MARK MANDEL: You're
so happy about it?
I think, for me, I'm going to
talk about another thing, which
I love, because so
often this is just
interesting and quirky
and interesting.
The amount of stuff that
happened around the big data
and machine learning stuff.
That's super cool.
We had a variety of open
data sets that got released,
the open images dataset,
geospatial data sets.
We released the cloud natural
language API, the speech API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The vision
API is also there, I guess.
I guess it was right before.
But yeah, so many APIs.
MARK MANDEL: So many APIs.
I love the articles, and the
stuff that came out of it.
The discussion of
micromovements of baseball.
Can you hear the
game through data,
I thought was
really interesting.
And by far, my favorite, is
basically the Japanese cucumber
farmer who was using
TensorFlow to manage
his crops, which is phenomenal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is certainly amazing.
I mean, the fact
that you had to talk
about cucumbers at the
Google Cloud Platform Podcast
is kind of amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I think it just
goes to show the wide
variety of things
that are possible once
you have the capabilities
at your fingertips.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So it
just blows my mind.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I guess
it's time for my last one.
And I guess it's not
surprising because I've
been playing-- not
as much as you,
but it is about Pokemon Go.
And Pokemon Go, I think
it was a great story.
It was an intense story.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
The hype was real.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If
we take into account
that Container Engine
was generally available,
we announced it
August 26 in 2015.
And a little bit later on,
I think it was in June,
something like that, all of a
sudden Pokemon Go is released.
And it's running on Kubernetes.
And not only it's
running on Kubernetes,
but it actually grows
to-- well, on GKE--
it grows to be the
biggest cluster ever.
It's huge.
And not only that, but on top
of that, they're happy about it.
And from the experience, we
created this new team, CRE,
Customer Reliability
Engineering,
which I think it's a great
thing to say, oh, SREs are cool,
but why don't you get
access to them as a client?
So, yeah, let's create
a customer reliability
engineering, which
I think is great.
There's a blog post about it.
It was very good.
And then also lots of
people were running on GKE.
I think that we
interviewed Tim [INAUDIBLE]
from [INAUDIBLE]
lab, and I thought
that it was pretty amazing.
And they were talking
about how they
were running their whole
thing on Kubernetes
and accessing Bigtable, which
is like, how Googlers do it,
right?
It is very much like--
MARK MANDEL: It's like Google
for everyone else, which
is great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm very
happy about the whole thing,
about GKE growing so fast,
and people getting so excited.
And Pokemon Go basically,
exploded in popularity
and still being successful.
So I'm very, very, very happy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no, I
totally, totally agree.
The velocity of
Kubernetes and GKE
has not slowed down
in the slightest.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
yeah, it's crazy.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is amazingly crazy.
And basically, Pokemon Go
served-- what-- everybody?
Just everybody.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, so my final one.
I just want to highlight
it because it's
something I helped create.
And it made me
feel very special.
And I love what's
going on there.
The Google Cloud Platform
Community Slack team,
or the Slack
community there, that
has grown into such a
wonderful community.
I'm so I'm genuinely proud of
it because so often sometimes I
just sit back and I watch it.
And I watch the people in the
community, the Google Cloud
Platform Groups.
Just interact with each
other, be nice to each other,
help each other
out, really just be
there for each
other, which I think
is just a delightful thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and I guess
we owe a shout
out to The Podcast
Channel in the community.
They're amazing.
I think it's pretty cool to get
so many questions of the week.
We don't get that many cool
things of the week from them.
They should send them, too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We get definitely get
questions of the week
from various people.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We get
questions of the week,
and they help us so much.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So just a huge fan.
If you're not on the Slack
channel, check it out.
Everyone there is really lovely.
And there's lots and lots
of people there looking
to help other people
out with what they do
and how they're building stuff
on Google Cloud Platform.
It's super cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I think it's a nice way to
finish the episode, thanking
the whole community
for being there
and thanking all our audience.
I think that we got a
crazy amount of audience
over this year to the
point that we decided not
to take a break in the summer.
But we're definitely
taking a break
now because we deserve it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
No, I just want to second that.
Everyone who's listened
to us, we love you.
It's been a great
year of growth for us,
and we're super happy
about the podcast.
And we have huge things
planned for the upcoming year.
I will definitely
say though, if you
want to put in the comments,
put in the podcasting thing,
put it in Reddit, or reach out
to us on Twitter, or whatever,
tell us your favorite episodes.
Tell us your
favorite cool things.
We'd love to hear what were
your favorite moments, either
on the podcast or cool things
that happened at Google Cloud.
We would love to hear
that back from you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And if you
want to send those as audio--
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We're always-- we're
trying to make
that a thing, where
we get some of the audience
talking to us directly.
That'd be fun.
So I don't know how
you're going to do that.
Maybe on Twitter or just post
it on SoundCloud or whatever.
MARK MANDEL: You can
post it on SoundCloud.
You can put a file on Dropbox
or Google Drive or anything.
Just send us a link.
We'll make it work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I guess that it is time to
say goodbye until January 18.
And would you like to share
your plans until then?
MARK MANDEL: I'll be
around San Francisco,
just having a nice
vacation and getting ready
for the craziness
that is next year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you said
the magic word in there, Next.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
So Next next year, there are
details on that live already.
So you can go to the website.
You can buy tickets right now.
Also making plans, personally,
for the game developer
conference here
in San Francisco.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: I know you have
a variety of events as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
So I'll be coming back.
Actually by the time we
publish the next episode,
I'll be back to Europe.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm going to Europe
for Christmas,
and then I'll be back there for
a Go Lab [INAUDIBLE] in Italy.
And then I go to
FOSDEM in Brussels
at the beginning of February.
So yeah, and after that
India for a GopherCon.
And after that, Next.
Fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Sounds like fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Sounds like lots of fun.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds
like lots of fun.
All right then, Francesc,
well, thank you to you
for joining me for
yet another week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you for
joining me for a whole year.
MARK MANDEL: And I guess I
won't speak to you next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No.
Yay.
MARK MANDEL: All right then.
Well, then I will
see you next year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]